وفي خرسان جنوبيه اوكرانيا افادت القوه
الاوكرانيه عن مقتل مدني وجرح اخرين في
قصف الروسي على المنطقه واضافت ان الجيش
الروسي قصف المنطقه اربع 54 مره خلال
الساعات الاخيره كما افاد الجيش الاوكراني
عن قصف روسي مكثف استاذفا البنيه التحتيه
فكري فيري بمقاطعه دينيفو وسط جنوبيه
اوكرانيا اضافه الى تعرض ضواحي زفروجيه
لقصف بالصواريخ دون وقوع اصابات
اتحول الى شبكه مراسلين من دنيا السلام
خضر ومن اطراف خرسون تامر الصمادي تامر
اطلقنا على تطور الجبهات في خرسانه
المشتعله
نعم جلال عدنا للتوم من داخل خيرسون نحن
ناقف الان على اطراف غيرسون
ولا نستطيع ان نظهر من هناك لان الاتصالات
منعدمه بالكامل شبكه الانترنت منعدمه
بالكامل والقصف متواصل نتحدث عن نوعين من
القصب قصف متبادل بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه على طول نهر دنيبر هذا النهر
الذي يفصل غير سون الى قسمين القوات
الروسيه التي انسحبت من المدينه غير سون
قبل اسبوعين من الان همم يعني ترابط على
طول الضفه اليمنى بعد انسحابها وتقوم بقصف
المدينه والاقليم بالكامل والعديد من
القرى والبلدات والقوات الاوكرانيه تقف
على الضفه اليسرى وتقول بانها تقصف
بالمدفعيه
مواقع تواجد القوات الروسيه هناك وتتحدث
عن انها تقطع طرق الامداد وتقصف طرق
الامداد الواصله بين ضفه دينيبر التي
يتواجد فيها التي تتواجد فيها القوات
الروسيه بالاضافه الى شبه جزيره القرم
تقول بان عتاد كثير يصل من كان يصل خلال
الايام الماضيه من شبه جزيره القرم الى
القوات الروسيه العالقه على ضفه نهر دنبر
كما تسميها وتصف ذلك وتشير الى ان هذه
الامدادات تقطع شيئا فشيئا وانا القوات
الروسيه لن تتمكن من الصمود ربما
لثلاثه اربعه اسابيع على ابعد تقدير لكن
في الحقيقه جلال وانا اتواجد في غير سون
قبل ساعه من الان
مررنا بعديد القرى هذه القرى التي تقف على
خط النار على خط الجبهه هذه القرى قصفت
بالكامل استطيع القول بان زلزال حقيقي ضرب
تلك القرى كل البيوت التي صادفناها على
طول الطريق نتحدث عن مئات البيوت هذه
البيوت مدمره بالكامل المركبات مدمره
بالكامل دخلنا الى احدى القرى التي لا
تبعد من هنا سوى كيلو او اثنين كيلو متر
فقط هذه القريه باتت معزوله مهجوره
بالكامل السكان فروا منها السلطات
الاوكرانيه تناشد وما زال تناشد سكان في
خير في عموم اقليم
بالانسحاب الى من المدينه الى مناطق اكثر
من نعم